thank you I'm Deborah Haynes from Sky
News
um could you just say has the UK seen
any evidence that South Africa has
provided weapons to Russia and are you
able to say whether or not Storm Shadow
has been used yet in Ukraine and against
what and for the Norwegian Minister
um are you able to say whether it's more
likely than not that Russia was linked
in some way to the nordstream attack and
is this new agreement with the UK today
going to make it much less likely that a
nordstream attack can happen again in
the future
um so look on the first point I'm I
can't comment on uh you know anything uh
that I may or may not have seen relating
to another country
if it isn't a public statement by those
countries so I I don't think I'm afraid
it falls into the neither confirm or
deny anything in that area on the Storm
Shadow all I can say is it is my
understanding that uh it has been used
uh
since we announced its deployment to
Ukraine but I'm not going to go any
further details of that operation
yeah and I can't really say anything
particular about the north streams
attack there's been an ongoing
investigation I think LED from Sweden
and Denmark
when we signed this agreement today it's
because
there is a lot of infrastructure on the
seabed in our part of Europe
and we need to protect this as Ben said
you know Norway is the largest supplier
of energy to August to to the continent
and to the and also to the United
Kingdom
we have been working after North stream
attacks to
to monitor this infrastructure
Markham here the maritime command has
been very important and in in in we have
been working with close allies to to
monitor the situation both
subsea and at sea
but we it's a ongoing work and we have
to look at how we can be even better to
Monitor and protect this important
infrastructure